what's with the jeans we got to wrap
this up pretty soon oh you want to see
this real quick because we've been
really high on ours succulent Chinese
meal and a lot of people have been
asking about it on the show here is a
well let you just see what you're not
you wouldn't use a dry paper towel to
wash a dirty car so why use dry toilet
paper to clean up in the bathroom yeah
yeah need water to get clean
yeah improve your bathroom routine and
get completely clean with a new bidet
buddy
look traditional toilet paper is rough
and stretching but the day buddy spray
gently washes you clean paper gets messy
paper can be expensive paper with the
bidet buddy you don't have to worry
about any of that wait a minute but you
still have to use paper you dummy
well yeah but all I can think about in
this ad is just thinking of this woman
taking a shit me too everybody that
speaks in this I'm like just picture
them shitting I picturing her wiping not
chewing and I love the argument is you
just don't want to waste toilet paper
yeah instead of like hey it feels nice
in there she also said like you ran out
of paper like now you don't like it's a
big problems in every household paper
yeah it's an efficiency save money yeah
picture me taking a shit right now
would not even and this nice blonde lady
take shit so they take shits I never
would've thought that listening this
lady but then she does even help clean
you feel after you go to the bathroom
now I picture her with like the sweetest
cleanest little asshole this sounds like
a pink waxed okay just super clean
asshole relax you just want to eat up
the bed okay relax
I don't like go to the bathroom she
should just say it's specifically for
shitting this product I've literally
never felt like
water the toilet paper just pushes the
wipes leave residue behind
yeah through anybody uses fresh water to
rinse you clean leaving nothing behind
now why didn't they use brown stuff for
this this is like purple purple is an
interesting color choice make it brown
so we know what you're talking about
black or red this is deep deep blood red
yeah you're probably so used to seeing a
lot of blood when you go to the bathroom
with a bidet buddy
all that blood gets washed away you're
used to pools of blood leaving you when
you sit down to go potty
now with bidet buddy all that blood gets
flushed away credible and you can adjust
the water job for kids
she high-fived him she's like watch you
little asshole yeah high five years I
like the firm setting sounded really
firm yeah that sounded like a hose I
don't know if you wanted that hard on
your ass why not happy she is that her
son's has a cleaner parents two roads or
IBS and he's so happy
he's like he's got a newspaper under him
it's like my daddy's gonna come over and
use her bidet my grandson clean is an
asshole and my old assholes clean too
needs of the day buddy
I'm a truck driver I said all day you
know he could take a shit yeah that's
what that's what he's saying he's like
I'm a truck driver
so you know I can shit yeah nothing
cleans like the bidet buddy
I just love it it's just easy and toilet
paper
nope it's fine they're making this sound
like you bidet as opposed to using the
toilet paper yeah it should be in
conjunction in addition to yeah water on
your asshole yeah wow what a neat
commercial thank you
yeah man pretty good stuff move god